welcome back to the spooky season
special which we like to call shocktober
in the last episode we were given an
introduction to the occult sciences as
they have existed in the islamic world
in particular a topic that is very broad
and which of course deserves a couple of
dedicated episodes to cover properly
and one of the most popular and
important forms of what we recall could
call occultism or even that very
controversial word magic in the islamic
world is the science and employment of
talismanic magic
[Music]
[Music]
when it comes to magical practices in
the islamic good world there is a whole
lot to go through of course because we
are dealing with a very wide span of
time
about 1400 years at least and of course
a wide geographical area as well the
word magic itself comes with a lot of
problems but as we have seen in the last
episode the closest equivalent to that
word in arabic is the word seher which
also carries a lot of
bad and negative associations sometimes
we argue that we shouldn't call some of
these sciences and practices actually
magic
because magic
can have these associations directly
with demonic forces or to
invoking things like the gin rather than
invoking god which is
what the majority of what in the broad
sense what magic is actually doing in
the islamic world for most of history
but in any case we will be using the
term magic here in a general sense to
talk about these things including
talismans and talismanic magic in any
case various magical practices certainly
took place and were common in the
islamic world during the middle ages
from the earliest periods after the life
of prophet muhammad and especially
during the later middle ages around the
12th century when it became to use
matthew melbourne kushki's words
de-esotericized and became mainstream on
a much larger level the magical or
occult practices in the islamic world is
hugely diverse of course it includes
many different techniques and sciences
that is
in some way employs superhuman forces to
influence the world now the majority of
quote unquote magic in the islamic world
is protective in nature it's magic that
tries to protect oneself from the evil
eye it's a very common example to
protect
oneself from other
magic or indeed just from evil forces in
general but these things also worked in
the reverse in that actively helping
someone for example gain good fortune or
heal a sickness that they were inflicted
with or to attract a lover perhaps a lot
of different ways that these kinds of
talismans could be employed one sought
these protective powers usually or
almost exclusively from god or sometimes
his angels or other intercessory figures
as we saw last time this was one factor
that differed magical practices in the
islamic world from other cultures before
and after the fact that the majority of
quote-unquote magic although not
exclusively of course invoked the
monotheistic god and his power rather
than other superhuman forces and the way
this worked was usually through various
forms of talismans so protective objects
or
amulets a lot of the time
that were imbued with usually god's
power that could help the person in
various ways indeed even though magic as
a concept is often looked down upon as
on islamic by many in the islamic world
today these kinds of talismans can very
commonly be found in a middle eastern
market or in the homes of people
stemming from this region i'm sure that
many of us have seen the protective
amulets against the evil eye that can be
bought in bazaars in istanbul
or seen the very famous and often
beautiful hand of fatima adorned the
home of a friend or family member
these are all examples of talismanic
magic and has always been a major part
of the culture in the islamic world even
in a contemporary european or american
context how many times haven't we heard
someone or seen someone have a lucky
charm that they carry with them or some
object that brings them
comfort or or good luck in a general
sense this is the same phenomenon
something that exists across a wide span
of different cultures not just the
islamic world but what is a talisman
really and how is one made this is a
fascinating topic and luckily there is a
lot of material from which we can draw
to learn about it
during the middle ages there were many
books written which were either
exclusively dedicated to or at least
included sections about magical
practices such as these the ejuana safa
or brethren of purity included a whole
epistle in their grand work specifically
to seher or magic
and two of the most famous grimoires or
magical books in history the
hakim or pikatrix probably written by
the andalusian muslim
and the shams al-maarif attributed to
ahmed al-buni both of these deal with
these very topics
sometimes we find clear instructions on
how talismans are made what techniques
to use for what etc a talisman can
technically be any object
you're probably thinking about some kind
of necklace with a locker or something
and that can definitely be one form of
talisman but a talisman can also be just
a piece of paper it can be a bronze bowl
as we will see and it can also be
clothes
which we'll also see examples of the
important part was that these objects
were imbued with power so god's power
usually and the most common way of doing
this was by imprinting certain symbols
writings or images onto these objects
some of the most common ways of turning
an object into a talisman would be to
write on it the names of god in arabic
primary of these is of course the name
allah but one also finds other names
like
the merciful or al-ahed the one etc
if not god himself then one might write
the names of one or more of his angels
such as jabril or mikhail one can also
write the names of his prophets perhaps
muhammad moses or solomon
for many shiites one might also write
the names of one of the imams or
spiritual successors to prophet muhammad
very common is also to write the shahada
or muslim proclamation of faith
there is no god but god or also direct
verses from the quran
many verses like the ayat al-arsh or
throne verse were thought to be
especially powerful in this sense in
other words there was a lot of writing
on these talismans
words and phrases were the primary way
that these objects were imbued with
protective power
many talismans such as these are often
very beautifully adorned with arabic
writings or in the case of jewish
practitioners perhaps hebrew writings
but there isn't just writing on these
things there is also various mysterious
and esoteric symbols that are often
imprinted quote in the earliest periods
we find an abundance of various
figurative images symbols that probably
carried over from pre-islamic practice
and symbolism
the earliest surviving talismanic
objects reflect pre-islamic magical
symbolism for example a longhorn stag or
oryx occurring on very early iranian
amuletic objects for about the 9th
century and remarkably stable but
complex design also occurring on 9th and
10th century amulets composed of a
scorpion rampant lion or dog a canopy of
stars and a frame of pseudo-riding
later other symbols became more popular
in particular a group of seven magical
symbols came to be widely used in
talismanic magic and other magical
instruction
these symbols were in some traditions
thought to be the seals of various
prophets and taken together they also
represent the seal of the almighty or
god
the most famous and widely used of these
seals is the so-called seal of solomon
often depicted as a hexagram or
pentagram
according to islamic tradition the
prophet solomon or suleiman in arabic
was especially associated with the
esoteric and
magic if we
define that word broadly it is said that
he was given a magical ring by god which
had this particular seal on it and which
allowed him to control
the jinn and other spirits as well as to
talk to animals and understand their
languages
solomon is a central figure in the
mythical history of islamic occult
sciences for this reason and the symbol
of his seal became a very important
talismanic symbol and devised during the
middle ages it later also carried over
into europe and western esotericism as
well
i think many of us have seen the seal of
solomon without necessarily realizing
its historical background and
significance
we see it return again and again in
these kinds of magical or protective
objects just look at this amazing
talismanic scroll from fatimid egypt for
example
another kind of symbol that was very
popular especially in the later middle
ages is something known as magic squares
these were as the name suggests squares
in which various numbers or sometimes
letters representing numbers were
written into separate columns
big deal you may think well the thing
about magic squares is that they are
always designed so that if you add up
the numbers in any of the rows whether
horizontally vertically or diagonally
you will always end up with the same
number
these kinds of squares again were
thought to be very powerful for magical
purposes
the earliest and most popular form of
magic square was the 3x3 variant as it
was obviously the easiest to make the
three by three magic square was also
called by the name budo
and if you didn't have the means or
skills of making one of these yourself
you could sometimes invoke the
power of this
symbol simply by writing yabudu or o
budu later more complex magic squares
were developed four by four and even six
by six and beyond which of course made
them even more powerful in the writings
of thinkers like the persian astronomer
abu bosjani we find instructions on how
to make these squares up to the most
complex 6x6 variant and they feature
also in later medieval works like the
shamselma artif one example of how these
magic squares were used in medieval
times is that they were often used to
help women in childbirth
so the particularly the three by three
magic square would be written on a pot
chart that had never touched water very
important and then this symbol this
chart would be placed in front of the
woman's face so that she could look upon
it and then the shard was also often
placed beneath her feet
and this is very interesting because
this practice is
apparently very widespread in the middle
ages and very commonly used to the point
that even someone like alexoali who is
famously very hostile sometimes towards
anything occult even he uses this as an
example of something that basically
everyone agrees works and then from that
he argues for the significance and
powers of numbers in general i think
it's a very very fun and i think
significant example to show how how
widespread these kinds of practices were
at that time
but as i've said talismanic magic or
objects could take many forms and be
used in various ways but all of which
with the purpose of either protecting
against something or to actively get
good fortune in some way there were
talismans that could be carried with you
in your pocket or around your neck for
example there were even talismanic
shirts like this fascinating object the
image of which was shared by one of my
patrons by the name of omar abdul
this talismanic shirt is as you can see
covered in symbols and arabic writings
like quranic verses
other talismans were hung over the bed
or the door of one's house there were
even some that were consumed to help
with some internal problem or illness in
other words there were talismans that
could be swallowed there were talismans
that were carried with you you could
wear talismans as clothes you could hang
talismans above your bed or above your
door
various different ways and objects that
could function as talismans but they all
had essentially the same function of
helping with some ailments or of
protecting against evils i've seen some
in the comments and in our discussions
elsewhere that
many people bring up
examples of everyday talismanic objects
that some people might even not think
about like having
objects with quranic verses in your car
or in
at your workplace just general objects
that in some ways have
references to the quran or to god and
that is thus thought to help or protect
oneself in some way
this is all as i said this is all
examples of talismans and of talismanic
magic one of the most fascinating and
striking kinds of talismanic objects is
the magical healing bowl
these were used for specific purposes to
help with a particular therapeutic or
physical problem and is a practice that
goes back to similar bowls used in
earlier aramaic speaking contexts
the difference with the bowls in the
islamic context is that they are most
usually made of metal and almost
exclusively again invokes god just like
most islamic magic
and let me tell you some of these
objects are just absolutely amazing look
at this bowl it has everything it has
depictions of these symbolic animals
described earlier it has magic squares
the seal of solomon is there versus from
the quran it's just absolutely
magnificent
to some people the existence of these
kinds of objects or practices in the
islamic world may be surprising but as i
said in the beginning this stuff is all
over the place and these are just a few
examples as already mentioned one of the
most common symbols or images thought to
have protective powers is that of the
human hand
in arabic this symbol is often given the
name khamsa meaning literally the number
five but referring specifically to the
five fingers on the human hand
in a particularly islamic context the
khamsa is also often given the name the
hand of fatima referring to the daughter
of prophet muhammad and the grandmother
of all the shiite imams
two christians or jews it is sometimes
given other names like the hand of mary
and other such things but the purpose is
always the same the hand is thought to
ward off the evil eye a central and
recurring theme in protective magic
it often has the image of an eye on it
but can also be adorned just like other
talismanic objects with various symbols
or phrases like verses from the quran
for example
now interestingly the hamsa most likely
originates in a pre-islamic environment
being used as far back as in ancient
mesopotamia and has always basically
served the same role only being given
different associations and symbolic
functions depending on the religion or
culture that appropriates it in one of
the most significant occult works in the
history of the islamic world the shams
al-marif or son of knowledge attributed
to ahmed al-buni talismanic magic figure
prominently ahmed al-buni was a sufi
and writer most likely from either the
maghrib or egypt where he at least
passed away in 1225.
his writings are on sufism but he is
heavily involved with the ill mulhoroof
or science of letters and how it relates
to sufi practices like zikr
his work the full name which is
which may have only been partly written
by him actually is like a vast
encyclopedia of occult sciences as they
stood in the 13th century islamic world
and this book contains detailed
instructions on how to make talismans
using many of the techniques that i have
described here it is important to
remember that when we talk about these
subjects there is a tendency to speak in
past tense that is to talk about these
practices as if they were things of the
past and indeed the middle ages was a
significant period for the development
of occult sciences but we should not
forget that these things continue to
exist into the modern world from safavid
persia and mughal india to the ottoman
empire and all the way into the present
day i've had viewers reach out to tell
stories about how widespread such
practices are in places like indonesia
and southeast asia today as well but
it's also the case in the middle east or
north africa too of course the occult is
not something that only exists in the
past but today and all around us in any
case talismanic magic is and has been a
vast science that has been taken for
granted as a legitimate way of
influencing and affecting our lives and
the world around us you may believe in
the legitimacy of its powers or not you
cannot deny the significant role that it
has played and continues to play in the
wider world
i'll see you next time
[Applause]
let's do it
you